today we were working on kicks and
technique and these things sort of
tricks and spins and stuff every day
there's something that's easier and
something that's harder we wanted to
find a style that feels different than
the way that you see most women fighting
and film in general I would say that she
fights like a boy except that diminishes
the fact that she just fights like a
really really strong woman Tessa's
thrown herself at this in the most
extraordinary way just incredible
commitment to the physicality of the
part the minute you open the door Wow
someone's got a history Tessa was so
compelling and powerful and mysterious
God we talked so much in Hollywood about
representation of women and we need
really strong stand up parts for women
but we also need women that are in
conflict and are not so great
we need representation all across the
board Cole played by Tiger ytt
his incredible actor it's so funny
because I'd kept saying on he'd play
someone in this film you know yeah we
believe that you can do it this parrot
is extremely fascinating to me he's a
giant man made of rock stone and granite
and opal who knows what's beyond that is
a flesh-and-blood
[Music]
Sekar is ruled by the Grandmaster played
by Jeff Goblin and he's insane and
colorful and hilarious I pardon you from
life
the Grandmaster is the photo negative of
Odin he's in very high status figure he
does things with disco grandmaster
improvises I'm practicing now this full
section which includes me as Grandmaster
playing with a band we wanted that
character to be really memorable and
Goldblum is just perfect
I'm going back to Asgard a scart I can't
stand him all that familiar he turned up
Taiwan and blue solo I asked place ass
Berg eyes God I'll tell you this and
this is honest it was as good a time as
I've ever had cabbie Jackie Chan yeah it
was really fun exciting and I liked what
we were doing
to have this villain s be introduced in
such a strong way is really exciting
I've had incredible fun playing with her
because I think her capabilities are so
surprising and so unusual she's not
simply sinister actually
as somebody who's played the villain in
these films I understand the
responsibility is that she has a huge
presence which she can express
physically or verbally she just has this
off-kilter movement to her character I
was completely blindsided by some of the
happiest times have been baiting people
up nothing good
you